l'ethiopie au centre d'une polémique à
propos de l'aide humanitaire avec depuis
ce matin à paris un colloque organisé
par les associations humanitaires
justement dont msf médecins sans
frontières sur le thème du détournement
de l'aide
alethia la situation cette situation
ethiopie c'est le thème de ce deuxième
volet de l'enquêté menée par dominique
torrès et frédéric vasseur en afrique de
l'est
ils sont allés dans la région de gaujac
dans l'ouest de l'ethiopie
c'est là que les italiens mènent une
expérience sans précédent une expérience
exceptionnelle il faut bien le dire est
qu'ils ne vont pas règles pour autant il
suffit par exemple de savoir que la
somme engagée dans le projet que vous
allez voir atteint les 200 millions de
dollars cette exceptionnelle mais
regardez cela ressemble quand même à une
solution
ils viennent du nord de l'erythrée du
tigray du vau l'eau ils sont six cent
mille à avoir quitté de gré ou de force
des terres désespérément aride pour
s'installer dans des provinces plus
clémente dans le sud où ici dans l'ouest
du pays
tous ces hommes ces femmes aujourd'hui
recensés dans leurs nouveaux villages
ont d'abord survécu à l'épouvantable
famine de l'année dernière mais aussi à
des déplacements de population effectué
dans des conditions souvent dramatiques
ces transferts ont provoqué le départ
d'ethiopie de médecins sans frontières
1985 la sécheresse un million de morts
mais combien d'autres durant les
déplacements l'urgence extrême de la
situation peut-elle tout expliquer tout
justifier cette famille est sorti du
cauchemar cet homme raconte qu'ils ont
perdu trois enfants durant cette période
ils sont venus ici volontairement
aujourd'hui ils attendent les premières
récoltes
affaibli déjà par la famine ces
populations déplacées ont dû faire face
également à des conditions climatiques
entièrement nouvelle ces gens viennent
d'une région de hauts plateaux alors
qu'ici on est à faible altitude
le problème le plus grave a été la
malaria mais maintenant le problème
n'est presque résolue si certains
organismes humanitaires ont décidé de
partir une quarantaine d'autres ont
choisi de rester en ethiopie d'aider la
population là où elle se trouve
passant de l'aide d'urgence à
l'assistance planifier à long terme
mais le projet le plus ambitieux est
certainement celui du gouvernement
italien
en quatre ans il prévoit de transformer
complètement la région du golan pour y
accueillir 300 mille personnes depuis
six mois les italiens ont défriché 7000
hectares construit 50 km de routes 35
font poser 35 km de canalisations et
diversifier l'agriculture prévue au
programme des hôpitaux des écoles une
centrale électrique
la conception des leds des compléments
différents de ceux qui jusqu'à présent à
savoir qu'elle n'est pas basée sur une
fourniture de produits alimentaires ou
ce déni des gens qui étaient là mais au
contraire c'était le fait de donner la
possibilité de
d'un décollage de
d'autres dirigeants sont alimentaires
agriculteurs autosuffisance alimentaire
c'est encore prématuré si effectivement
le sorgho le maïs en recommencer à
pousser dans le gault jammes une grande
partie de cette population déplacée est
encore dépendante de l'aide humanitaire
internationale
moi je suis venu du nord je suis venu
volontairement dans ma région il ne
pleuvait pas ici il pleut suffisamment
les récoltes peuvent pousser ici tout
est vraiment bien
le gouvernement éthiopien montre la
région du golan a qui veulent avoir ici
même des esprits chagrins trouverait
difficilement à redire mais le cas est
exceptionnel
les italiens ont la situation en main
c'est eux et eux seuls qui dirige les
opérations
quelles sont les structures d'accueil
dans le sud et ailleurs où la population
est également déplacé début 1987
l'aide internationale d'urgence doit
s'arrêter il transfert de population
reprendre au moment l'ethiopie semble se
tourner davantage vers l'occident
des choix décisifs sont nécessaires la
solidarité oui ni à quelles fins et dans
quelles conditions